l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de monsieur philippe dominati à
madame la ministre de l'égalité des
territoires du logement sa parole
si monsieur le président madame la
ministre le mois de février 2012 je vous
rappelle les faits les cnil a mis en
lumière le fichage massif par paris
habitat la société de l'office de hlm de
paris qui concerne 125 mille locataires
des annotations concernant le caractère
privé des locataires et des usagers
c'est et natation sont particulièrement
fortes
alcoolique chômeurs en fin de droits
séropositif n'est pas de nationalité
française sous chimiothérapie
bref un fichier pour le moins curieux
massif et dénoncé par la cnil à
plusieurs reprises on sait on a évoqué
cette situation et on voulait savoir ce
que le gouvernement comptait faire
c'était l'objet d'une question
d'actualité il ya un an et à chaque fois
on nous a dit mais on suit son cours on
va voir ce qui se passe et c'est un an
après aujourd'hui je souhaiterais savoir
où on en est un audit devait être fait
je sais qu'il a une remise en ordre
une remise en ordre technique une remise
en ordre je dirais sur le logiciel pour
autant où sont les responsabilités
quelles mesures quelles conséquences
qu'elle suit le gouvernement à donner à
ce fichage massif des locataires
parisiens des locataires qui sont les
plus faibles des citoyens de la ville de
paris où parmi les plus faibles qui ont
rarement la possibilité de se défendre
qu'avez vous fait voilà le sens de la
question je sais que techniquement vous
allez répondre en partie mais je
voudrais savoir que au delà de la
réponse technique réellement quelle est
l'action du gouvernement pour protéger
les plus faibles
et pour éviter que ce genre de dérives
se reproduisent et enfin surtout définir
les responsabilités
est ce qu'on a mis la poussière sous le
tapis et ce qui est effectivement on a
pu définir les responsabilités de ce
fichage massif des locataires parisiens
voilà le sens de ma question
merci mon cher collègue la parole et l
onem fleur pellerin mini chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises
d'innovation et de l'économie numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alors en effet les
manquements relevés par la cnil en
décembre 2011 lors de sa mission de
contrôle du système informatique de
paris habitat n'avait en réalité pas de
caractère généralisé puisqu'il
s'agissait de cas relativement isolées
très isolé même d'enregistrement non
pertinent est réalisée sans qu'aucune
instruction n'a été donnée
en outre paris habitat a engagé un
travail de fond afin de répondre aux
attentes de la cnil ce travail a été
présenté à cette dernière dans un
mémoire en réponse qui traduit un
engagement concret est la mise en oeuvre
de cette démarche mémoire qui a
d'ailleurs donné lieu à plusieurs
réunions de travail avec les services de
la commission parmi ces engagements
ces engagements pardon figuraient
notamment la nomination d'un
correspondant informatique et libertés
lequel a été nommé le 8 juillet 2012 en
application des procédures définies par
la cnil le correspondant exerce sa
fonction avec l'indépendance et
l'autonomie d'action en cohérence avec
son statut
la réalité de la mise en oeuvre de ses
engagements a pu être vérifiée lors de
contrôles réalisés par les services de
la cnil puisque par courrier du 19
juillet 2012
la présidente de la cnil a décidé de
procéder à la clôture
à la clôture de la mise en demeure de
paris habitat
dans ce courrier elle a pris acte des
mesures prises par paris habitat et
noter que sur certains domaines
les mesures prises vont au delà je la
cite vont au-delà de ce qui était exigé
dans la mise en demeure en tout état de
cause le maire de paris a écrit dès le 3
février 2012 au président les trois
autres organismes liés à la ville de
paris en leur demandant d' une part de
vérifier sans délai la stricte
conformité de leurs pratiques en matière
d'enregistrement des données
personnelles d'autre part de présenter à
leur prochain conseil d'administration
les mesures mises en oeuvre pour
garantir le respect de la loi la rivp la
6ème place gym devenu et logis les trois
autres organismes concernés ont réagi
très rapidement est indiqué notamment
que leur gardien n'avait pas accès au
système de gestion des précisions ont
été apportées en particulier en termes
de conservation des données et de
vigilance rappeler aux équipes sur
l'utilisation des éventuels champ libre
commentaire
dans les applications de gestion une
présentation des mesures existantes a
également eu lieu lors des conseils
d'administration de ces trois organismes
et puis enfin la suite du traitement de
ce dossier
la cnil a engagé une concertation
nationale avec les acteurs du logement
social
selon ses propres termes consciente des
problèmes que peuvent rencontrer les
bailleurs sociaux dans l'application de
la loi de 1978
la cnil souhaite faire évoluer sa norme
simplifiée et proposer un pack de
conformité tenant compte des évolutions
du métier de bailleur social requise par
l'évolution des politiques publiques
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce que fait
la cnil pour répondre à votre question
si le sénateur si vous voulez répondre
madame la ministre vous m'avez répondu
sur la compétence de la cnil et la mise
en conformité du logiciel mais en
finalement personne n'est responsable
et personne n'est coupable dans cette
dans ce fichage concernant les
locataires parisiens le gouvernement sur
le plan de la justice devaient savoir ce
qui se passait était ce la direction de
l'entreprise et sd et phénomène isolé
est ce une initiative individuelle tout
cela un an après on ne le sait pas on a
donné des instructions on a soi disant
régie pour que ça ne se produise plus
mais il n'y a aucune fuite
en réalité on a voulu masquer cette
action on a voulu la masquer parce
qu'elle était dérangeante bien
évidemment et pour autant vous voudriez
avoir un souci d'exemplarité dans le
domaine du numérique des fichiers et
données des responsabilités un organisme
public l'office de hlm
cent vingt mille locataires qui fait un
fichage personnel des locataires il se
passe rien et vous voulez donner un
exemple notamment aux jeunes sur le
numérique et sur les fichiers mais je
pense que votre réponse est faible c'est
pas la vôtre ma table ministre c'est
celle du gouvernement le ministre de la
justice avait été normalement informé le
ministre de l'intérieur ou si en réalité
vous éluder le problème vous faites en
sorte qu'il ne se passe strictement rien
donc on ne peut pas être évidemment
satisfait de votre réponse